Hey right-wing radio host an NRA
spokeswoman and all-around gun nut dana
loesch appears to be plagiarizing hatred
mail patriot mail as you might know is
the segment we've been doing on the show
for years we're a professional deep
voice movie and TV voice-over artist
does these dramatic readings of hate
mail that I get as a reminder here is
his voice here is like a sample
introduction that we use for hey tree of
male teachers can buy their own school
supplies but we'll throw in the Glock
for free Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom so the guy
who does hatred mail for us noticed that
dana loesch he was listening to dana
loesch I guess he listens to right-wing
radio just for kicks and he wrote the
following letter to me he said hey David
so I was listening to crazy right-wing
radio today in the car because it's
funny anyway as I was listening to Dana
Loesch is show she plays this segment
opener with an announcer who says
something about reading hate mail then
Dana comes on and says she's going to
read emails Facebook posts etc by people
who hate her not only that she says
she's going to read them in a dramatic
voice and include all grammatical errors
what the hell it would appear that she's
copying hatred mail so I checked it out
I don't want to cast aspersions on
anybody's asparagus when they are not
warranted but this sounds a hell of a
lot like hatred mail take a listen to
the intro alright well you know what
it's time for because we were moving
well like a hey since we have a guest
next hour I know I got some insane hate
mail for you let's kick it and now it's
finally that part of the show where Dana
monetizes the hate all week Capel posts
tweets replies and emails have been
collected the best-of-the-best make the
cut its mailbag of hate on the Deena
show these are real emails sent by real
people real tweets real Facebook posts
from living breathing haters they vote
they drive on the highways beside you
they gosh it's kind of crazy that is
hatred mail that is hatred mail let's
listen to a little bit more by the way I
don't know how anyone listens to this
show this is this seems like one of the
worst radio shows I've ever heard of
let's take a listen to a little more of
it so and I will read them dramatically
so that's how I know so this was crazy I
got this story this is from skip Mulkey
and unless you're totally horrid I don't
share your email address if you're
completely horrid I forward everything
to federal authorities to determine
whether or not it's actionable and I do
take action I will take you to court
like I've never not followed up that's
literally what I say I say that the
really insane stuff goes to the FBI like
this is almost verbatim Patriot mail and
then we save all the hatred mails in
case we get subpoenaed this is what we
do this is their stick let's listen to
just a little bit more here and I win
every time so don't test me because I
have the resources to do it
so don't because I mean yeah anyway this
one's from skip Mulkey and the subject
is abortion skip rights and again I will
read this with grammatical errors and
everything else intact right I heard you
just say on the radio about a last got a
culling of kaboom I'm already bored as
soon as she went into the act that's not
dramatic that that's just a really bad
fake English accent isn't this obvious
hatred mail right please tweet the Dana
Loesch tell her that I've been doing
hatred mail for years and she should
find out who on her staff listens to the
David Pakman show because it's just too
similar I know I for one I'm going to
boycott the Danish show until she gets
rid of this segment I'm also no longer
going to listen to that show and by no
longer I mean the one minute I played
for you is all I've ever heard of it and
it really doesn't sound good but they're
copying hey tree at mail